I haven't had Japanese McDonald's before
but I'm very interested in what they
have we actually came here doing soccer
a season and it happens that McDonald's
is actually selling limited edition
soccer s stuff this is the toughest
soccer soccer a McFlurry I can't quite
tell what's inside this McFlurry but
it's gonna taste like flowers it's
actually pretty good it's not too sweet
it tastes like cereal sort of cherry
flavor it's like if you took all the red
fruity pebbles and put them into ice
cream those Giga bacon te Tama what does
Teddy time I mean just teriyaki an egg
oh I see okay
Fisher hmm here's Evan please they're
like a lot of flavor topping in my mouth
you should put eggs more often burgers
Japan really knows how to do their eggs
usually a light bacon crispy like I want
my bacon to be like oily and like you
can literally snap it in half don't get
me wrong it doesn't taste bad this is
the medal shake I know that there's a
lot of Japanese flavor candies and stuff
this melon flavors is actually pretty
decent and it has a slight tang to it I
would describe this as a less citrusy
creamsicle I wouldn't order it every
time I come to McDonald's I'm usually
not a big fan of melon flavor but in
this shape form I'm pretty okay with it
this is the shakashaka chicken chukka
means shake and basically what you do is
important like powder inside the chicken
bag and shake it
she's drums a little strong this is like
a cheesy and neat form it's basically
like a big piece of Cheetos but with
chicken hidden shaking up your food is
fun though we should have more of that
in the station all right so this is the
EPI feeding in English it's supposed to
be the trim fillet I'm very excited
because I love shrimp the first thing we
have for shrimp sandwich is a po-boy
hmm I like fish it kind of tastes like a
fishy chicken I definitely want this to
be in the space this is so good I think
there's something wrong with your taste
buds shop this is the sucker Evie seal
fries you pour it into the fries it
smells a lot like shrimp chips and I
love shrimp chips why was it it tastes a
little bit too strong in comparison to
shrimp chips you bite into it and you
think like oh it's a little salty but
then just spice like rises in your
throat I thought that was a roller
coaster of emotions only the burgers are
good but I think I'd prefer the sweet
stuff definitely try to come during
stock Racing because it's not just the
food it's also just beautiful here I
think America McDonald's might have to
step up their game a little more
I think mom if you